before we start today's episode check
this out it's our brand new
what if 100 book it features the 100
most popular what-if scenarios
as suggested by you learn more and get
this special collector's piece
by clicking in the link in the
description below
it's big it's scary
and it has an appetite for destruction
meet godzilla king of the monsters
think you're having a bad year so far
how about if we woke a dormant giant
reptile that shoots
plasma beams of radiation from its mouth
[Music]
what would happen if godzilla woke up
could a giant creature like godzilla
exist
and how would we deal with it
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if godzilla were real
godzilla or gojira as it's pronounced in
japan
has been a popular cultural figure for
over half a century
appearing in comic books television
video games and
cinema with over 36 films made about
this giant lizard
we seem to know a lot about him
interestingly each year godzilla seems
to get
bigger and bigger
some of the stories suggest godzilla has
been in hibernation
like the siberian salamander which can
stay frozen
for four to five months in a process
known as
reptilian brumation
[Music]
if global warming sets it free what
exactly would we be in for
well before we get to the grim details
let's first look at what we know about
this
massive beast
based on our most current films godzilla
is estimated to be about 110 meters tall
and weighing somewhere between 14 000
tons
and 164 000 tons
theoretically the largest animal that
can exist without being
crushed by the earth's gravitational
field is
1100 tons even if godzilla's weight was
on the
conservative side of 14 000 tons
it would still be 14 times heavier than
this theoretical limit to withstand
earth's gravity he must have some
pretty strong bones according to the
square
cube law which states that as an object
increases in size its volume will grow
faster than its surface area certain
bodily functions like
the rate at which heat is lost
the rate of digestion or the speed of
oxygen reaching the brain
are dependent on mass and wouldn't work
the same way at godzilla's scale
from a biological standpoint in order to
move around
the fastest speed that brain signals can
travel
is 100 meters per second so at 110
meters tall
it would take over a second to send a
signal from godzilla's brain
to its feet talk about lag it would also
need a massive heart weighing thousands
of tons to pump
all its blood through its body and
to power this giant organ among others
godzilla is going to need a lot of food
[Music]
hi can i get the extra extra extra extra
large combo please
oh no it's not for me it's it's for a
friend
based on climber's law which states that
an
animal's metabolic rate scales to 0.75
power of the animal's mass godzilla
would need
approximately 15 million calories per
day to put this in perspective
a blue whale will eat around half a
million calories
per mouthful so what exactly would it be
dining on
well luckily godzilla has a taste for
radiation just as flowers absorb
electromagnetic radiation from the sun
to survive
this helps to power his radioactive fire
shooting abilities
[Music]
no i'm not making this up
so what happens if godzilla doesn't
like us
if we're going by modern standards an
angry
skyscraper-sized godzilla would likely
trigger tsunamis earthquakes and
utter chaos
and to add insult to injury godzilla's
radioactive plasma jets would
spread radiation poisoning to any
creature living nearby
for miles making chernobyl seem like a
safe zone
if we tried to blow it up well
because of all the nuclear energy
godzilla snacks on
we'd be facing a bomb 100 times the size
of
sarbamba the largest bomb ever exploded
so we'd either have to find a way to
cooperate with it or
build giant robots for the ultimate
showdown
as a short-term solution godzilla
could be a tourist attraction for the
most extreme travelers
that is if he doesn't swat any incoming
jets from the sky
a creature of this magnitude could
harness a lot of energy
especially with so much nuclear power
surging through it
theoretically godzilla has the potential
to supply
1200 households with energy every day
that is of course if we could find a way
to restrain him
or maybe a giant hamster wheel could
work i'm just spitballing here
but in the long term we'd have to deal
with the massive
costs to repair cities and to move
people to safe areas
we could also be looking at a potential
nuclear fallout that would leave
several places simply uninhabitable for
many generations
if we found a way to communicate with
the beast
maybe it could be used for good like
battling
invasive alien species catching rogue
missiles or
using godzilla as a wake up service for
the heaviest sleepers
thanks at the very least
its massive presence could help unite
the world in a mission for
survival and peace which could stave off
international conflicts
maybe an army of murder hornets
might help slow him down well
that's a story for another
what if
you